inflation is crushing pakistan and we
just got news that the imf is now going
to step in the imf has officially
extended a brand new loan to the country
of pakistan their idea is that they want
to avert a potential default and they
want to pave the way for more aid
according to bloomberg this imf loan is
important because pakistan needs at
least 41 billion dollars in the next 12
months to repay debt and fund imports as
foreign exchange reserves shrink to a
level that could only cover less than
two months of their imports now of
course whenever you see money sloshing
around the next question should be
what's their inflation rate and is it
getting better or is it getting worse
steve hank one of the economists that
people pay attention to in some of these
emerging markets he pointed out that his
current calculation of pakistan
inflation is at a stunning 43 percent
year-over-year he said that recently the
imf agreed to release 1.17 billion
dollars in funds for pakistan but he
doesn't believe that another imf loan
will save pakistan's economy like all
the past imf loans this one will fail as
well
now as we take a look at the global
standings of inflation we can see that
pakistan sitting with about 40 percent
or more inflation they're doing better
than places like ukraine leos venezuela
argentina cuba zimbabwe but sitting with
more than 40 percent increase in prices
year over year isn't exactly reassuring
to the people on the ground now when we
look at these local economies what we
have to remember is that the growth of
the money supply ends up creating issues
but it's not just the government
themselves the more debt that they take
on as they try to inject this capital
into every corner of their economy it
ends up driving more and more money
chasing fewer and fewer goods the
country of pakistan with more than 40
inflation is already in trouble but they
have so much debt that they can't pay it
back and so now here comes the
international monetary fund they're
going to step in and they're going to
give them more debt in order to be able
to pay off the old debt that's like an
individual consumer saying i have my
first credit card and i can't pay it off
so let me take out a second credit card
to pay off the first one and then when i
can't pay back my second credit card
i'll take out a third credit card to pay
off the second more and more debt is not
the solution ultimately we need to
return to some sort of sound money
digital sound money where it is not
based on countries taking on more and
more debt
punishing the value of the money that is
held by their everyday citizens we need
a world where people can save till
financial security and we need a world
where it's not based on how much debt
can you take
and how can you go and beg people like
the imf for more money ultimately the
citizens of pakistan they want to live a
happy life they want to simply pursue
financial security for them and their
families
and what we have to do is start to
implement first principle solutions to
these problems or we simply kick the can
down the road create more volatility
create more problems and ultimately
relearn the lesson decade after decade
after decade market intervention will
never be as sustainable of a solution as
allowing the free market to solve our
problems